Ich bin hier, der Saarböden ist.
Ja, ich bin hier, der Saarböden ist.
Wie heißt ihr jetzt?
Mein Name ist Maja.
Jonas Maja.
Können Sie bitte langsam vor uns nachnehmen,
Also ich habe jetzt immer wieder Luftnot und insbesondere nachts mit Brustschmerzen.
Und ich weiß nicht, was ich machen soll.
Herr Meyer, Sie haben Luftnot und Brustschmerzen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Bescheidung?
Ich habe das immer wieder jetzt.
Ich habe das jetzt wieder seit drei Wochen ungefähr.
Vor drei Wochen.
Und zunächst einmal haben Sie diese Bescheidung.
Ja, habe ich das auch gehabt, jetzt habe ich es wieder.
Herr Meyer, habe ich richtig herstanden.
Vor drei Wochen haben Sie diese Bescheidung angefangen.
In der Zwischenzeit erleben Sie immer wieder diese Bescheidung.
Genau.
Gut.
Okay.
Haben Sie momentan wieder Bescheidung?
Aktuell nicht, ich habe nur ein bisschen Luftnot.
Okay.
Ich kann auch bei Königinusien, Bitsumen, der Espechübre, herzwergen.
Ich denke schon, ja.
Gut.
Okay.
Herr Meyer, Sie haben gesagt, dass wir Brustschmerzen haben.
Wo genau sind Sie schmerzen?
Ja genau hier auf der Brust.
Ja, okay.
Wie beschreiben Sie die Schmerzen?
Sind Sie eher dumm, wenn du zurückkommst, oder?
Das ist eher so ein Dummverschmerz, den ich habe.
Okay.
Schraben die Schmerzen, ihr seht vorhin auf?
Nein.
Ja, sind die Schmerzen belastetabhängig?
Ja, gibt es etwas, das Ihre Schmerzen verschlechtert,
aber es ist auch besser.
Ja, also wenn ich mich belaste, dann habe ich mehr Luftnot.
Weil bei der Luftnot haben Sie Luftnot in Ruhe?
Nur auch manchmal, aber mehr bei Belastung.
Hab ich Luftnot.
Okay.
Nur Luftnot oder auch Brustschmerzen?
Brustschmerzen habe ich nicht immer.
Okay.
Ja, beide Bescheide, wie stark sind die Schmerzen,
die ich meine Brustschmerzen,
wobei 1, 2, 3, 4, 7, 8 Schmerzen sind?
Die Brustschmerzen sind so bei 4 oder so.
Okay.
Herr Rubaja, wie alt sind Sie?
26 Jahre.
26.
Wo genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 15. März 1998.
15. März.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,80 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Circa 75 kg.
75.
Herr Rubaja, haben Sie viel wahr?
Nur habe ich nicht gemessen, ich denke nicht.
Ist Ihnen überall oder haben Sie erbrochen?
Nein, manchmal, wenn ich rusten muss,
dann ist mir schon übel, aber nicht so stark.
Okay, bei rusten ist Ihnen überall?
Ja, genau.
Bei der Bescheide haben Sie noch andere Bescheide,
wie meine Übel oder Erbrochen?
Wie meinen Sie, was meinen Sie genau?
Bei der Bescheide, bei der Luftmolte,
dass Sie es rusten müssen, haben Sie noch weitere Bescheide.
Nein.
Wir haben einen Rusten.
Ist das ehemalige oder...
Es ist trockener Rusten, aber nicht immer.
Ich bin nur sehr stark Luftmolte.
Waren Sie schon einmal wegen dieser Bescheide
beim Arzt oder im Krankenhaus?
Noch nie.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserwassern
oder einen Lieblingszugang?
Wie ist Ihr Fatih?
Gut, sehr gut.
Ist Ihnen in letzter Zeit gewiss Veränderung?
Ich bin schon immer 75 Kilogramm.
Haben Sie Allergie?
Ja, ich habe Allergie.
Keine Allergie.
Polen Allergie.
Ich habe eine Polen Allergie.
Wie hat Ihr die Allergie ausgesagt?
Ich habe immer Yukreis, Augennässen
und es kratzt in meiner Nase und einem Rachen.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente gegen Allergie?
Nein.
Manchmal nehme ich Zitrezin ein, aber ganz selten.
Ja, Zitrezin hilft Ihnen, oder?
Ja, macht nur müde.
Macht müde.
Deswegen nehme ich das nicht so oft an.
Ja, verstanden.
Ich nehme das nicht so oft.
Ja, genau.
Herr Meier, rauf uns die.
Bitte?
Rauf uns die.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Manchmal.
Wie meines?
Um bocheneinander.
Wie viel?
Kommt noch ein.
Kommt drauf an.
Was meint ihr, wie viel trinken Sie?
Was trinken Sie am Wochenende?
Unterschiedlich.
Kommt drauf an, unterschiedlich.
Verstanden, okay.
Herr Meier, ich nehme das, wie kann ich das nehmen?
Unterschiedlich.
Herr Meier, leidt es dir, wie viel trinken Sie?
Nein.
Wurde es dich einmal operieren?
Ich wurde mal am Sprunglenk operiert.
Ich hatte einen Bruch.
Ungefähr 10 Jahre.
Ungefähr 4, 10 Jahre.
Das Bruch.
Wie bitte?
Genau.
Noch weiter?
Ja, wir haben,
das Herr Meier,
die manchmal
Okay, Herr Meier, sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Ja, eigentlich schon.
Also, Sie haben jetzt keine Beschwerden.
Mein Vater bluthoch trock und meine Mutter ist gesund.
Wie sind Sie, Geschwester?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Einzelkind, gut.
Wie ich, ich bin auch Einzelkind.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin leh nicht. Ich lebe alleine.
Ja, Sie haben keine Kinder.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Informatiker.
Sie leben allein? Okay.
Ja, Herr Meier, sind Sie gegen Corona oder Griechbe geimpft?
Oder gegen Kinderkrankheit?
Gegen Corona habe ich mich empfangen lassen, aber sonst habe ich keine Empfangen.
Ja, warum sind Sie in der Stadt im Ausland gewesen?
Dieses Jahr nicht. Also, ich war nur hier in Deutschland.
Herr Meier, ich würde Sie Ihre Vor-Opie-Geschichte surgkommen.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie hatten, ja, die wurden wegen Schupurkelexburu operiert.
Vor zehn Jahren.
Was ist Ihre Seite?
Links.
Links, gut.
Herr Meier, ja, im letzten Zeit, vielleicht haben Sie Haustiere gekauft?
Nein, ich habe keine Haustiere.
Okay, oder haben Sie umgezogen?
Ja, neue Wohnungen.
Ich bin auch nicht umgezogen, nein.
Okay, verstanden.
Okay, Herr Meier, ich habe hier alle wichtige Fragen für mich gestellt.
Sie haben etwas hinzufuggen oder haben Sie noch Fragen?
Wollte das ein Herzinfarkt sein oder was am Herzen, weil ich so Brustschmerzen habe?
Ich habe ein bisschen im Internet gelesen, da steht, es könnte ein Herzinfarkt sein.
Ja, Herr Meier, ich denke nicht so.
Sie haben momentan keine Bescheide, Sie haben keine Brustschmerzen.
Ich denke, Sie haben, natürlich, genau etwas zu sagen, jetzt ist so für, dafür brauchen wir noch weitere Untersuchungen.
Aber natürlich habe ich eine Serte auf vielleicht Asma Bronschale.
Sie haben schon Polaralergie und manchmal erleben Sie Brustenanfall und Brustnotanfalle.
Ja, diese 5-Werten sind für Asma Bronschale, aber das ist nicht herzdiasende.
Ich habe schon gesagt, dafür brauchen wir noch weitere Untersuchungen.
Momentan haben Sie keine Luftnot, keine Schmerzen.
Momentan haben Sie keine Bescheide.
Nein, nicht.
Okay, gut.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Nein, ich würde gerne wieder Sport machen, meinen Sie das kriege ich hin.
Ich habe jetzt seit einer Woche kein Sport mehr gemacht, weil ich die Luftnot habe.
Was haben Sie denn für einen Moment?
Natürlich.
Momentan haben Sie keine Verzüge, keine Schmerzen.
Sie haben keine Brust, keine Brust, keine Schmerzen.
Ja, natürlich, die Gegenden erfunden sich, vielleicht eine allergie-Teste oder eine Atmung-Teste.
Ja, in dieser Situation brauchen wir noch weitere Testen und Untersuchungen.
Ja, aber zuerst werde ich Körpern nicht untersuchen und Brust abnehmen und Brust von der Zeit verhandeln.
Nach der Ergebnis der Ekonöle, darüber noch mal besprechen.
Okay, dann warte ich jetzt.
Gibt es sonst Fragen?
Ja, ich habe einige Fragen.
Sind Sie in der Saison heiser?
Nein.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlucken?
Haben Sie einen sauren Geschmack im Mund?
Nein.
Wie viele Kisten benutzen Sie beim Schlafen?
Eins.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich kann flach liegen, ja.
Haben Sie Ausrüftung?
Ja, ich habe keine Ausrüftung.
Danke schön.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit besonders morgen Geschwoldene Bein bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Haben Sie eine Schmerz beim Einatmen oder Ausatmen?
Manchmal, ja.
Welche Einatmen oder Einatmen?
Wenn ich Luftnot habe, habe ich auch Schmerzen.
Erleben Sie früher einige Luftprobleme?
Ja.
Ich habe das schon mal vor ein paar Monaten gehabt, aber das war nicht so stark wie jetzt.
Ich habe das Gefühl, wenn es kalt ist, wird es mehr.
Wenn ich in der Kälte spaziere oder wenn ich laufe, dann habe ich mehr diese Luftnot.
Ich habe das Gefühl, im Sommer hatte ich gar nichts.
Ich habe das Gefühl, wenn ich in der Kälte spaziere, dann habe ich mehr Luft.
Okay, dann kommen wir zum Ansatz.
Guten Tag Herr Oberhass. Ich habe einen neuen Patientin.
Jonas, maya, 26 Jahre Patient, kam zu Ulgun Atemnot und Toraz Schmerzen.
Momentan hat er keine Beschwerde, aber ihre Beschwerden haben vor 3 Wochen angefangen.
Der Patient beschreibt die Schmerzen als Dunfernde. Die Schmerzen sind nicht aus.
Die Beschwerden sind belastungsabhängig.
Bei der Beschwerde hat er auch Lust.
Er hat auch Lust.
Er hat Lust.
Darf man sich jetzt Polen-Allergie anziehen, die Allergie an sich mit genügend Allergie einnehmen,
dagegen nimmt er manchmal Z-Sin ein und Z-Sin nicht ihm, aber wegen Müdigkeit oder Schlafsricht
nicht einnehmen.
Nikotinkonsum, die Frage nach Nikotinkonsum und Rodenkonsum wurde verneint,
der Patient trinkt gelegentlich Alkohol, der Patient hat keine Erkrankungen
und vor zehn Jahren, wegen der Schlafsrichter-Kostschmerzung,
nimmt er bei Bedarf, Paracetamol oder Iduprofen ein.
In der Familienanamnese, bei der Vater, die Tester, die Patronie, seine Mutter hat eine Erkrankung.
Darf man sich jetzt einziehen, lehnt und wohnt allein, arbeitet als Informatiker,
ist gegen Corona geimpft und Reisanamnese ist unauffällig.
Die anamnistischen Angaben deuten am ersten auf eine Osnobrönsche allehin.
Die Franziadiagnostischen Kommunen folgen der Erkrankungen im Besserastas,
der Reflugkrankheit und der Erkrankung.
Um die Franziadiagnostischen Menschen zu bestätigen,
werden die Folgen der Masse an den Durchführern,
als die körperliche Unterhörer und Polutabnahme und Zurachstöntgen veranlassen.
Wir haben jetzt eine Artmunktest.
Artmunktest?
Jungen Funktionstest.
Sollte sich die Pferdaktdiagnose erharten,
werde ich folgende Therapien entfädeln.
Natürlich mit allergen, Kontakt mit allergen,
mit den Sprechen, mit den Strophäen.
Und als Therapie Bronke-Dilatator-Therapie
und als Immigraler-Steroid-Therapie.
Ja, das war es.
Was nehmen Sie denn an Blut?
Ich habe nicht mit den Patienten verstanden,
dass sie die allergenen Pferdaktdiense aus dem Asthma haben.
Was ist das für eine Erhörter-Allergie?
Das sind die älteren Erhörter, die die Erhörter-Allergie sind.
Erhörter-Allergie ist eine Erhörter-Allergie.
Und eine Erhörter-Allergie bei der Bundesflugnagoren.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und machen Sie auch einen Röntgen-Torax bei den Patienten?
Ja, andere Dunkelkrankheiten.
Genau, ich mache keinen Vorstand.
Andere Dunkelkrankheiten auch verschieden sind.
Bei der Asthma erwarte ich die Asthma nicht so bestimmte Zeichen.
Aber andere...
Könnte ja ein Blut-Ax haben?
Genau, manchmal ist es möglich.
Aber der Patient hat diese Besperre, seit drei Wochen
nicht immer mit Anfalle erleden,
die erleden diese Besperren des Ökens.
Das schippt sich gegen die Ärzte.
Gut, also Sie nehmen Blutab, die Untersuchten den Patienten,
ob er auch in Atem geräuscht hat,
ihnen frei von exploratorischen Verlängerungen eventuell.
Ja, bei der Dunkelkrankheiten erwarte ich bei den Patienten,
aber nicht immer Asthma bräuchte die Anfalle,
bei der Anfalle hören wir diese Geräusche.
Und Lungenfunktionstest, worauf achten Sie da?
Ja, mit Lungenfunktionstest beurteilen wir
die Anfalle der Dunkelkapazität und die Atem-WG-Könünferung.
Ob es eine Ferangunk gibt bei Atem-WG.
Natürlich, wenn der Patient keine Besperre hat,
bei der Lungenfunktionstest-Könünferung etwas nicht wissen wird.
Worauf achten Sie bei Lungenfunktionstests am stärksten und am meisten?
Auf welchen Wert?
Ja, natürlich.
Bei der Lungenfunktionstest möchte ich Sie als Lungenfunktionstest
noch etwas erzählen.
Ja, zur Wahl der Patienten, bitte atmen Sie tief ein
und halten Sie tief.
Dann kann ich bestanden, das ist okay.
Das weiss ich, wie das funktioniert.
Auf welchen Wert achten Sie?
Ja, in einer Sekunde, ja, ja, dann sagen wir,
dass es ein bisschen, atmen Sie aus sofort, wie möglich.
Wie heißt dieser Wert?
Der Wert, leider habe ich keinen.
Ich habe dir gesagt, eine Sekundenkapazität.
Ja, genau.
FEV1, schon mal gehört, FEV1, Tiffenode Text, ne?
Ja, FEV1, ja.
Wissen Sie, wie hoch der sein muss?
Wie viel Prozent?
Vielleicht 70 Prozent.
Ja, sehr gut, gut gemacht.
Sehr gut.
Ja, sehr gut.
Wahrscheinlich hat er ein Asthma-Bronchialen,
muss man kontrollieren, man muss bei der Lungenfunktion
darauf achten, dass man noch den Bronchyspatmolusetest macht.
Man lässt einmal die Lungenfunktion machen
und dann hat man einen Wert von 65 vielleicht
und man macht dann nochmal nach Saibutamol in der Nation,
macht man nochmal und wenn das reversibel ist,
ist das meistens Asthma-Bronchialen.
Ja, ja gut.
Okay, muss dieser Patient im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Ja.
Nein, der Patient hat keine Besprache der Momentan,
deswegen können die ambulanten Therapie entführen.
Ja, würden Sie ihm etwas geben, damit er besser Luft bekommt?
Ja, nochmal bitte.
Würden Sie ihm etwas an Medikamenten geben,
damit er am Wochenende besser Luft bekommt?
Ja, in Hallesterit und in der Therapie würde ich empfehlen.
Saibutamol kann man erstmal probieren,
in Saibutamol ohne Konkison
und später vielleicht besser,
dann kann man auch in der Latvipkontisturin geben, ganz genau.
Sehr gut.
Ja, sehr gut gemacht, gute Fragen stellt.
Einige Fragen kamen zu spät,
zum Beispiel hätten Sie fragen können,
ob der Patient mehr Sport macht, sportlich ist,
ob die Beschwerden bei Sport auftreten,
hätten Sie fragen können.
Wichtig wäre gewesen, dass Sie vielleicht das Alter am Anfang fragen,
wie alt der Patient ist, nicht erst in der Mitte,
damit Sie wissen, ob das ein COPD-Patient
oder ob das ein Asthma-Patient sein könnte.
Ja, wegen akustisch Problemen am Anfang
bin ich ein bisschen erschöpft geworden.
Okay, okay.
Es ist aber ganz gut gewesen,
ich spreche in ganz gutes Deutsch finde ich, sehr gut.
Ja, danke schön.
Nicht gut.
Gibt es sonst Fragen,
irgendeine etwas unklarer Ergänzungen?
Kann man, kann man,
Saba Sama sagen bei der Therapie,
Saba Saba.
Kann man sagen, ja.
Saba Sama, Saba Sama, Saba Sama,
kann man auch machen, insbesondere bei COPD-Patienten,
aber das war eigentlich ein einfacher Fall heute,
nicht zu schwer,
wie der Dr. Selim hat er gut gemacht.
Ja, das war gut.
Sama.